[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream number
61 happy new year to you
all for you heather and for i assume
everyone in our audience
it is january 2nd 2021
i am still stuck in late december i have
some work that i didn't finish
and i will be catching up to you all in
2021
in maybe a week and a half two weeks
tops hopefully you're not the guy who at
the silica gel
who caused 2020 but if you're the guy
who gives us
a 40 day december 2020 i'm gonna come
for you no i think it's it's just it's
just me
i'm i'm just you you know and uh it's
interesting
2020 i can tell you is now quite
deserted
i seem to be the only one here i'm glad
to hear it yes
things still go wrong though sure the
toaster exploded this morning
flew out through the window and put a
hole in our new porch
what's going on in the kitchen yeah that
explains a lot
i i thought it'd explain something yeah
um all right so uh today we are going to
do a few announcements first which is
going to start with and we're going to
talk about frog poisons of course
uh the diets of some amazonian peoples
uh move from there to a natural segway
into vaccines uh
some drug treatments that are not
vaccinations
for covet and then finish it up by
talking a little bit about
the mayor of portland ted wheeler who is
still the mayor
after this last round of elections will
we be making recommendations for dietary
upgrades for amazonian people no we will
not
we will not all right well that's a
shame you'll know i will uh teaser
some of them seem to specialize on
macaws they eat very large parrots
oh yeah i have something on that which
you don't know that i have but
when we get there i don't all right so
announcements yes um let us start
with um we have added some
items to the i am not going to say merch
i just won't yes there you have it on
your screen now the first against the
wall
club we have some shirts and hoodies and
stickers and cupcakes and things like
that
so anyway i did want to say a word about
what first against the wall club means
what it is supposed to evoke it was a
very popular thing that was discussed
on the podcast and many people requested
that we get some stuff out there in the
world
what first against the wall club is an
allusion to
is the fact that the the enemies of
reason
are not likely to be nice if they
win and that in some sense we are
watching an epidemic of cowardice which
is
allowing this woke revolution to take
over
the world and if we're going to to beat
it
we have to get over the cowardice and so
there's a
a sense that one of the things one
really has to do is
you have to find your courage and you
have to budget for what that means and
it means
confronting the um the
understanding of the fact that you will
not be treated well
uh if they win but what it really means
is not that any of us want to end up
against the wall i certainly don't
expect to be lined up against the wall
myself and the reason i don't expect to
is because
i know that failure is not an option
that we can and must win and
so we will do it um
so anyway if you are of like mind then
consider i don't know uh the first
against the wall club
and uh grabbing a mug and also
it occurred to me that we are frequently
asked about what
uh advice we can give people who are
facing um a
woke confrontation of their own and it
occurs to me that
one thing you could do to encourage
people to find uh
their their strength and their
willingness to say what's true in spite
of the risks and hazards
um would be to i don't know give them a
sticker or if you don't want to buy a
sticker you could write out your
own card inviting them to the first
against the wall club
final thing i'll say is the recognition
of the hazard of standing up
against these sorts of foes
is frightening but you get used to it
and many many humans have
confronted very frightening things
because history demanded it of them and
we are no different in this regard
um we are lucky that we are not facing
a literal battlefield with bullets
but nonetheless it is our obligation and
future generations
require of us that we um that we become
courageous and
fend this off because everything seems
to depend on it
so if people are interested in that
where do they find it oh they would find
that
at the here we go dark horse
it is store.darkhorsepodcast.org
that will take you there all right so
hopefully you enjoy those things
um second announcement is uh it's
sort of a correction it's an odd one
some of you will have noticed that the
podcast that we did
live last week was briefly unavailable
and then went
back to availability the reason for that
is that we discovered that a story that
had been forwarded to
us that we had talked about
the story about a trans woman in the
evergreen locker rooms we discovered
that that story
though it was forwarded to us in the
present was not modern
and we thought it was modern at the time
we pulled it down to make sure that we
hadn't said anything that wasn't right
we went back and looked at it carefully
we didn't say anything
that was incorrect and so we elected to
put it back up as
is but do know that we should have known
that that story
took place in fact in 2012 when we were
at evergreen somehow that story did not
make it to us
which i still find surprising indeed but
uh in any case
uh apologies for the error but like we
said
the story and nothing we said in there
is untrue
so um and the original episode is uh
unadulterated back up
yep all right so that that takes care of
announcements
it does so uh let us start uh with
a tale of frog poisons and the awful
terrible very bad
new york times and and from there
in part because i ended up finding this
story just fascinating about
the differing diets of some of the
brazilian and peruvian amazonian tribes
but also as just an indicator of how how
one can
end up in interesting scientific
territory um
by following some sort of chain of of
um of research and and links
uh to end up someplace really unrelated
to where you started um
so first though uh we
uh found yesterday
this story in the new york times
um can you poison your way to good
health west coast wellness elites think
combo an amazonian frog poison drug is
helping them purge toxins in quotes from
their lives
note that toxins here is in quotations
but if you go down to the third
paragraph and i have lost control of my
screen again
um you can read combo long used by some
indigenous tribes in south america as a
sort of rain forest vaccine
is not a recreational drug you don't
trip and the tangerine trees and marbled
skies since
did they say vaccine um
i can't imagine why they would have said
vaccines right
it's an incredibly irresponsible
especially in the modern moment
use of this term and um
so i because i do not have access to my
computer i cannot
um do i have it back there we go um
later in the same article if you can
just give me a screenshot real quick
here bret
zach um literally one of the subheadings
of the sections is a rainforest vaccine
question mark
and um you know i haven't i have yet to
explain what this is what th what this
is this it's this frog it's a highlight
which is a tree frog and um actually a
propeller conversation our phylogenetic
conversation last week tree frog can be
both an ecological descriptor
um a frog that hangs out in trees and is
adapted for trees
um and it is also a phylogenetic
description of all of those frogs
that are in the group known as hyalide
the family of um quote-unquote tree frog
so this
um there's this frog phyllo medusa
bicolor which is also known as the
like the amazonian monkey frog the
amazonian leaf frog they're a lot of
common names so the reason that you use
the latin term is that
there's only one scientific name
binomial phylomedusa bicolor
when captured and hassled
as is the case of many other rainforest
frogs including the ones that i studied
both in the new world the dark poison
frogs in madagascar the mantellas
when hassled they will produce a white
exudate on their skin
and that is that is toxic that is
poisonous
um this toxin that phylomedusa bicolor
produces
is totally unrelated to the lipophilic
alkaloids
um i think that are present in the frogs
that i studied yeah which
it would be expected based on the fact
that in spite of the fact that both
men telling frogs oh they're not man
italian frogs anymore are they
um oh man telling from totally still
works out uh and this is the
those are the malagasy uh poison frogs
and the poison dart frogs
which were um dander babies are they
have they been moved they're still
dendrobat tids
um they they you've split the genus into
oophagia in various okay
good enough they're still dendrobatids
that's fair okay so
the point is despite the fact that
ecologically speaking these are both
heavily tree associated clades
these are neither of them highlights
they're not tree frogs in the
phylogenetic sense they are tree frogs
only in the ecological sense and so
you would expect that a toxin that was
unique to these groups
could only be found in highlights if it
was
separately and convergently evolved and
it is therefore no surprise to find that
some other toxin many frogs
many amphibians in fact are toxic and it
is not surprising to find that some
other toxin has evolved
presumably to dissuade uh predators yeah
well i mean this
well there's lots of little little
fingers to go down here but just because
you mentioned it with regard to
convergence of diet
uh in fact these two really distantly
clades of frogs that are not the ones
that produce combo but the dark poison
frogs from the new world
um and the uh mantellas
from madagascar do have um the same
class
of alkaloids that they produce in their
skin which therefore produce the same
kinds of
really undesirable effects in those who
eat them and that is in fact
convergently evolved as a result of them
sharing aspects of their diet it is the
ants and mites in the frog's diet
that produce that provide the building
blocks for the alkaloids that the frogs
then convergently produce
and i actually did not there there is by
the same by the same
researchers who discovered the nature of
the chemistry
in the frogs that i worked on myers and
daley there is some work on these guys
on filo medusa i did not track it down i
don't know to what we attribute their
poisons but it's different
so combo which is the name of this
um this oh boy i just don't have my
computer
there we go yeah that might be that
might be useful um okay
um well we'll just see if it's working
at the moment
no it's not uh yeah zach i think you
just need to give me my computer and
okay we are having i don't know why um
i'll solve it okay okay um
so combo um
has been has been described as this as a
vaccine by the new york times but in no
way
is it it is in fact of course a
toxin that produces strong purgative
effects
and um and you know diarrhea as as well
both you know vomiting and diarrhea
very quickly upon upon taking it and
it's sort of
it although i have not seen it called
this um
it sort of seems like it's the first
hour or two of ayahuasca with none of
the
euphoric hallucinogenic effects that all
the bad part of iowa
all the bad part and none none of the
euphoria
some of the people in the amazonian
tribes who actually do
do use it do report
oh i'm a better hunter afterwards uh i
have a reduction in pain
you know it's not it's not clear this
work has mostly not been done
um but what it's definitely not
is vaccinating you against anything and
so the reason i first went to this story
was not because oh
amazonian rainforest frogs i know
something about those i'm interested and
in people
but in what the hell is the new york
times doing
calling this a vaccine and it turns out
there's this
original the first description in
western literature of
people using this toxin in this way is
from a 1925 report originally written in
french in which the author
uses the french verb vaccine
which can mean vaccinate or inoculate
but that
doesn't mean that the local people were
saying that they were being vaccinated
nor
that the author of that paper actually
thought so and it is
frankly you know gross journalistic
malpractice
once again to be talking about
giving yourself a poison that causes
purgative effects
uh as if there is an
any kind of equivalent uh with regard to
uh
it being it being a vaccine sorry i'm
super distracted because there's all
sorts of tech stuff going on here
um so let us just point out
that the term vaccine i believe
comes from the latin bacca or some
version of cow and it is the result the
reason that it
um accompanies what we modern's
term vaccines is because jenner the way
he discovered
the process of vaccination this is not
the only time humans have discovered it
but
it is where the west derives its history
of vaccination
was from the observation that milkmaids
did not
get smallpox by virtue of having been
infected by cowpox which is a
trivially harmful uh infection that cow
that milkmaids got from milking
cows and that therefore created this
cross immunity so
the point is this process is in no way
it's not an arbitrary term at all it
applies to
the triggering of the immune system to
be alert
for something that it then sees later
which is pathogenic has
nothing to do with this process which is
i mean
is there a blanket term maybe medicine
is the blanket term they're looking for
although frankly if it's straight up a
toxin
it's it's even questionable if you call
it a medicine but medicine is at least
a plausible term that you could defend
it's a pharmaceutical it's a
pharmaceutical
it's not a vaccine it is not in any way
a vaccine and the new york times uses
this word twice
why because i mean i think because as as
we'll get back to later in this episode
the
the the very concept of vaccine has now
become
yet another completely polarizing
completely politicized topic and so
actually i forgot to ask him if i could
use his name so i'm not going to use the
name of the former student of ours yet
another former student of ours
who we were in touch with this week who
said
it's like maga hats and it's like
masks vaccines whether or not your pro
or con
has becoming the new star-bellied
snatches and stages without that you
know that reference to dr seuss being
one that i was using a lot earlier
in our live streams and the fact is
the idea that you are simply pro-vaccine
or
simply against vaccine is an insane
position
it's an anti-scientific position to
simply be opposed to all vaccines and
it's an anti-scientific position to
simply be in favor of all vaccines no
matter what
both of those are uninvestigated
knee-jerk
anti-scientific positions and the idea
that a large proportion of the country
seems to be really happy in one of these
two camps why
well in part because the journalists who
are the people who are supposed to be
interpreting
the high-level work for the rest of us
and giving us information which we can
use to decide for ourselves
are incompetent they are doing a
terrible terrible job
at the point that you call combo a toxin
from a rain forest frog that will cause
you to puke for two hours a vaccine
of course many people don't trust you
anymore
yeah it's uh this this will come up in a
couple
different ways um this is a hell of a
moment to
decide vaccines are all one thing or the
other this is exactly the moment
that we can't afford that but what
they're effectively doing here
is borrowing from the fact that for
their audience
vaccine is an unalloyed good which is
preposterous
and they are using that illegitimately
to cast this other thing in a positive
light now this other thing may well be
positive but
if they use the technically correct term
if they said pharmaceutical
right then the pharmaceutical has a very
ambiguous valence right we all have
suspicions about pharmaceuticals don't
we but we're supposed to think
um vaccines are an entirely different
phenomenon with you know no risks or
anything associated with them
and so in effect they are they are
abusing
the um illogical circuitry that we have
built around these for frankly nefarious
purposes
yep to um uh do
what uh eric has pointed out russell
conjugation russell being bertrand
russell
um basically the idea that one uses uh
slightly different wording to say things
that have the same literal meaning but
carry a very different emotional
connotation they're doing that they're
abusing the term vaccine in order to
borrow
its unjustified very positive
connotation
for this story about a rainforest toxin
right no that's i think that's that's
exactly right we do this is
uh very much related to smack in the
middle of this whole concept of wrestle
conjugation
yeah um that we can deceive with
language and have plausible deniability
afterwards
although in this case i would say there
is no plausible deniability this is
simply not a vaccine in any way it's not
related to vaccines yes they indict they
indict their own credibility they died
their own credibility yeah yeah exactly
now
just one more thing about the frogs i
was reminded reading this
you know the new york times article says
oh you know 10 years ago these people
would have been doing ayahuasca
in you know yurts in the backyards of
people in southern california
and now they're doing combo and you know
it definitely
it it it invokes an image like i got it
i'm right there
um and it also invoked for me
however um it reminded me of my very
first study abroad
program not actually at evergreen i ran
a study abroad program as you know
through an independent uh field school
before i started evergreen
after i got my phd and i had students
none of whom i'd met before meeting them
in panama we're in boca del toro
archipelago and i had students from the
u.s and from europe
and after one of the first days of uh
field work where they were supposed to
be
collecting some data on their own a
couple of them a couple of the couple of
guys
came back and told me they'd licked some
frogs and it's like
guys you have no idea what you're doing
like you you heard somewhere that some
frogs will get you high
and this is really not a safe practice
really not a safe practice but your
amphibians are actually
really well equipped to hurt you and
they don't have fangs like they don't
have teeth
well no so many of them the ones the
ones they were looking don't have teeth
some of them do but you know they they
don't come with spikes and horns and
claws and such
um they they come with the poisons in
their skin and not all of them are but
for
god's sake yeah you know get it get it
get it right let's do your research
it's frog roulette in the neotropics to
be yeah so
it is so first of all just to wrap
things up nicely yeah
the idea that harassing frogs uh causes
them
to exude this substance makes perfect
sense behaviorally because
in general it doesn't take much contact
with
a toxin for a predator to realize i
don't want to eat that thing which means
that
in many instances the animal will not be
killed at the point that the predator
realizes it's made a mistake right so
you know toxins tend to be very very
bitter and in fact
if i can confess you know the quick and
dirty way of figuring out whether some
fruit you found in the rain forest
is uh okay to eat is to take it and
dab it on your tongue and in general the
stuff that you shouldn't eat is bitter
as
all hell and the stuff you know
spandious
what i love finding on the forest floor
which is perfectly edible and delicious
that's the scientific name of this
beautiful it's canopy tree right
with with with fruits um that must be
dispersed at least in part by monkeys
because we
uh we like it too monkeys and bats i
believe
are the primary uh dispersers monkeys
sometimes being lousy dispersers because
they will sit in the tree and eat all
day and drop the seeds right under the
tree which the tree could do itself
without
making a fruit bats we don't need to
send it through a monkey to do that
thanks much right so bats are great
dispersers why because
two reasons one they fly so they tend to
if they swallow the seeds they'll crap
them out somewhere else
but they also have a very fascinating
aversion to hanging out in fruit trees
even the ones that eat only fruit don't
hang out in the fruit trees and the
interpretation of this
is that those fruit trees attract
predators
looking for fruit dispersers and so the
fruit tree is simultaneously a source of
food and a very dangerous place to be
which it's possible that the fruit trees
actually
have a branch structure that increases
the likelihood of predators to be there
in order to make the the uh fruit
frugivores nervous
so they'll leave and go do a good job of
dispersing anyway
yes it's an interesting interesting uh
story but the point is
your students who licked these frogs
probably would have the experience if
they found a particularly toxic one
would probably have the experience of
making their mouths very numb and
tasting something very bitter and
realizing they'd made a mistake
but there is the occasional numb is only
one like so numb
would be the effect from the dark poison
frogs like i have
stories about that maybe i'll share one
of them here today but some you know i
don't think combo actually produces for
instance numbness it's not going after
sensory neuron
um synapses um but
i would just point out that in the
gender badass
is really your story but uh the in the
dendrobatids there
are the occasional frog that is so
toxic that mere contact with the animal
is enough to
knock a person flat on their ass so
viola baby is terrible right had we been
in a place where that was true i would
have obviously provided them that
information in advance and told them to
stay the hell away and in fact
across um it's since been developed
which is a terrible
tragedy or at least it was in the
process of being developed and it's
possible it got stopped but
there was this is related but not quite
the same
um the highest density known of eyelash
fibers which is just this beautiful
snake named because it has these scales
above its eyes that look like it's
look like they're wearing this like you
know fancy fake eyelashes
um and they're trees tree snakes and
they come
in a plethora of colors they you know
usually um
in the rest of their uh distribution um
the rest of their range they're yellow
but on the serapto peninsula which is
just a short boat right away from this
field station we were at
there's sometimes pink there's green
there's sometimes pale with some
splotches
and i had actually one of the students
who had looked frogs earlier ended up
doing some research on these snakes
but i was over with him for the first
several times that he was there and i
made sure
that he was at you know not acting like
a yahoo because
you just you cannot operate the same way
in a tropical forest as you do in a
temperate forest or
anywhere in a place that hasn't been
made safe for you
um on because there is there is
no one who could possibly make it safe
yep
yeah and eyelash vipers being one of
these things even those of us who are
used to dealing with poisonous snakes
right the eyelash viper is where you put
your hand which is not the usual
for such animals yeah and they're little
too and they'll you know they'll they'll
bite you
little and inconspicuous and so uh as
you know i have a hypothesis about what
the
value of the eyelashes i find this
okay you can do it one of my favorites
no i'll use it why not
um so the i so unfortunately we don't
have a picture of this animal or this
would be much more
i can't get one well like even if i
could
i i don't no i can't okay um
so the eyelash viper has these little
like uh it's
scaly it's basically the same material
as the
the face of the animal and it sticks off
above the eye and these are
little vipers that hang out on
various plant parts and wait for prey
they're sitting weight
predators and being camouflaged is key
to their
um their niche and so as heather
mentioned there are
tremendously large number of colors even
within a brood as i understand it
you can get many different colors which
means so i wish we had one of our
pictures like you and i both have taken
some beautiful pictures
but um here's here's one this isn't a
very good picture
um here's one again showing the face
yeah that's tiny though um
yeah it's not these aren't great
pictures and i i didn't prepare for this
so i don't have
i don't have any of ours um anyway keep
going oh but there you go that's not bad
that's not bad can you show it can you
full screen it
not really there we go so there you can
see the little eyelashes that stick off
above the animal's eye so the hypothesis
and again this is a hypothesis as far as
i know completely untested in fact i
don't think anybody
has taken it seriously but no i didn't
i know i see look at you you're i'm
sorry i just remember you doing this in
class
and uh it was the first time i heard it
when we were teaching together and
i think i just started laughing but you
have no idea this warms my heart
so to be the only person who believes in
something and then
you know if this turns out to be right
which i think it's really likely yeah
i'll be thrilled
but anyway that doesn't mean it's not
ridiculous it is it's
nature is ridiculous so the hypothesis
is that this animal in order to do what
it does
it needs to find a place where it is
camouflaged in order to sit
and because you have many different
color forms of these snakes within a
brood
you can't just wire in you know you're a
green you're a light green snake look
for light green places to hide because
the animal doesn't really know
what color works right because
it could be any color and so if the
genome had that programmed in you'd
somehow have to coordinate
the color of the skin with the
preference in the eye and that's not an
easy job to do so
what about having a little eyelash that
sticks up that allows the animal to look
around
and match its color to the substrate on
which it's going to sit
so my boy it's like like why they're
snakes
why don't they look at their own tail
like
that's that's cool but like they're
snakes
they have a lot of bodies they can look
at and they're and they're pretty much
the same color
okay okay okay but if the animal is
looking around
by definition it will have its eyelashes
right where it's looking
right whereas having to sit somewhere
and pull its tail up and match it up to
some flower
while that would also be a cool
adaptation i don't think it's nearly as
cool as having just a little thing
so that this makes predictions one
prediction is that the eyelashes are
within the view
of the animal enough to work this way
and you're gonna find this out through
interviews or
yes that's how i'm going to find it i'm
going to ask the animals if they can see
their eyelashes
but also the prediction would be that
the eyelashes are never of a different
hue than the animal right true so uh
anyway things like that so this is how
we entertain ourselves it is
it does this and pinheaded truth so
there you go
um oh the last thing yeah yes
as long as we're on the topic um
amphibians
toxic our newts our local newts here are
maybe the most toxic pound-for-pound
animal on planet earth which was
discovered
through an accident where some hunters i
believe
had accidentally scooped a newt into
a coffee pot and then boiled the water
to make coffee
and were found dead and this alerted
people these must be very toxic animals
they searched and
something like um there's enough toxin
in
an individual newt to kill 50 average
people something like that
and i believe the story is not specious
that
um the people in north america who then
did work on terricogranulosis
and um and isolated the molecule
which they called tarika toxin based on
the genus name of the newt the latin
name of the new tariqa
went to present their work at some big
toxicology conference or some such uh
some
few decades ago this was this isn't 100
years ago this is fairly recently
uh and in the audience i think i've been
in the details right and i think this is
a true story
in the audience were the japanese
researchers who
had worked on the toxin that the puffer
fish
uh the genus for which is tatrotus i
think i may have that quite a little bit
wrong but they
actually were presenting at the same
conference to trototoxin uh which is the
toxin of the puffer fish
and i don't remember who was up first
but either the tariqa toxin guys with
the newts or the detroiter toxin guys
with the pufferfish toxin were up there
presenting and the other people were in
the audience
and they looked at the molecular
description the chemical description of
the
of the toxin went oh my god it's the
same thing
so it turns out puffer fish in the
western pacific and
uh newts on the west coast of north
america separated by
a large pacific ocean across which the
newts can not
cross and the puffer fish do not cross
um
have convergently evolved exactly the
same toxin right which makes
a weird kind of sense because all of
these toxins are basically
interference molecules with the
physiology of
critters and to the extent that critters
are variations on a theme
there's a limited number of molecules
you could build and there will be
selection for that which most
effectively disrupts the
creatures in question and so it's not
surprising that selection
again and again finds um well
you would expect it to find analogs you
would expect to disrupt the same system
what is a little surprising is that it
finds exactly the same structure that
interfaces with
right and in that case not because as
with as i already mentioned the dark
poison frogs in the new world the gender
batteds and the mantelas the poison
frogs of madagascar
have converged upon exactly the same
lipophilic alkaloids
but we can trace that to an
environmental similarity which is that
the building blocks for those alkalines
are in
the alkaloids are in the mites and the
ants that they eat even though
the species of ants and mites like the
species of frogs themselves
are complete are so distantly related in
madagascar versus the new world
despite having a gedwandan distribution
that is that is shared but we're talking
about
you know tens to you know well over 100
million years since gondwana has been
separated
anyway that you know by geography for
another time but yep um which is one
more thing about
um about these frog toxins when i was um
when i was in the business of tattooing
frogs which i was i remember this one
for a spell um only because i needed to
mark them in order to know who was who
in order to do the behavioral work that
i was doing on them
and i tried putting little beaded
waistbands around them and i tried a
number of things and none of it worked
in part um
it turns out the frogs have neither
necks nor wastes really
or if they have wastes that if you cinch
something tight enough you can hurt the
frog
and these are little tiny frogs so i
ended up
tattooing them which didn't please them
too much
and you have to be really careful
they've only got two layers of skinned
r3 so you have to be very very careful
and i had this little
handheld tattoo machine that i was part
of my field gear in madagascar
but much like the people in the
brazilian amazon who use various toxins
as you know as tips for their darts or
as you know purgatives for their own
health
uh you have to aggravate the frog in
order to get them to start producing
this white milky toxin on their skin
and i was never trying to that wasn't
part of my research i wasn't studying
their um their biochemistry or their
toxins
but what i found was that when a frog
was particularly squirmy and i had to
really you know hold it for a while in
order to get it tattooed
that even when i wasn't aware of it if i
had spent a morning tattooing frogs
and then was uncareful in the way that
many of us discovered we were at the
beginning of kovid and you're often
touching our face and such
that if i touched my fingers that had
been on the frogs
to my lips or any mucous membrane or any
cut
i would get a quick burning followed by
numbness that would last for anywhere
from a few minutes to up to an hour or
two
in one case and that this was very
clearly the toxin the lipophilic
alkaloids in these frogs
that was doing its work which is as i
mentioned earlier blocking
the synaptic transmission of sensory
neurons hence the numbness
against the numbness perfect sense yeah
yeah i should just say because certain
people will be wondering yes you had a
tattoo gun
on your study island in madagascar and
because the days are long there's not a
whole lot to do
you also at one point did my [ __ ] stamp
and i think you did very excellent work
oh yeah
are you gonna show it uh not not today
no um
all right all right that took a weird
turn yeah it did yeah
um okay but i actually so that also that
included a number of
i think interesting rabbit holes but um
as i was looking into this this combo
phenomenon which i'd never heard of
before i've i've run into this frog
follow medusa bicolor
but i've never run into combo and it's
and its uses before
i find in various of the of the studies
the suggestion that this anthropologist
catherine milton who actually we know by
reputation a friend of ours was her
graduate student and i guess you met at
some point
yeah i was on bci with her for some i
forget whether it was
weeks or a month but uh yeah katie was
on the island with me
so she was at that point so that would
have been in the 90s um
mostly a heller monkey researcher right
like that was she did these longitudinal
meaning long-term
like time-wise longitudinal studies on
heroin monkeys
but i was fascinated by the suggestion
that she after this french guy back in
the 1920s
had been one of two people uh in the
1980s to separately observe
um some people in that it was the
mayaruna tribe in the brazilian amazon
using combo in the way described that
it's currently being done in like new
yurts in southern california
um so i found um oh i'm not gonna be
able to show the paper
um well i found this paper okay
um so i found this cool thanks zach um
comparative aspects of diet and
amazonian forest dwellers
in which she looks at the dietary
ecology of
four forest living indigenous groups the
arara parakana arawete and maru mayaruna
i did not find here what i went looking
for which is her initial observation of
combo being used but
um this paper is actually super
fascinating
so zack if i may have this back for a
moment um
so she um i'm just i'm going to share a
few of the conclusions and then
show one more screenshot and then have
us talk about this a little bit
she she this is actually this is really
good work she starts with a hypothesis
which i'm not going to share until
the end this is not simple descriptive
this is not data-driven
this is hypothesis-driven science which
is particularly tough when you're doing
cultural anthropology um so she looks at
four tribes
all of whom inhabit uh what's called
terra firm amazonian forest there's a
lot of flooded forest there's
a variety of forests in the amazon
actually but these are all these
she she goes she goes looking for and
at four distinct tribes that are not
exactly saint patrick that is they don't
overlap but then tribes don't overlap in
the amazon and that's part of what's
going on here
but they inhabit very similar ecological
spaces right
that is to say um even people who know
the amazon could walk into the force in
which each of these four tribes live
and immediately see a lot of
similarities in terms of the species
composition
so um they all of them have distinct
both carb
the plants that they eat and prey
um diet compositions and i wanted to say
just a few words specifically about the
prey
so the arara are dietary journalists
specifically here i quote the arara
consumed the widest range of prey
species including stingrays and electric
fish
the intestinal tract of a wide variety
of mammals and pintos
milton reports in her 92 paper pinto
from 1989
reports that vultures house rats and
hawks are eaten by the aurora when other
meat is not available
but the single most important prey item
of the aurora was monkeys particularly
capuchins
okay so they they they get capuchins the
most
um they i don't remember if they state a
preference for capuchins some of the
other um
tribes do state of preference even when
it's not predominant in their diet
but they're really wide generalists so i
would just point out capuchins
are almost the only thing on that list
that sounds like it would be at all
palatable to somebody
who shares our diet because they're
frugivores
i don't want to eat um rats but yeah in
a pinch
yeah um yes uh completeness of
frugivores and frequents taste better
than
carnivores or omnivores yep um and full
of always taste
taste good too uh folivores
including grazers yeah grazing almost
all of our meat animals are full of
horses a
rain forest full of war might be
particularly awful by virtue of all of
the toxins in in the
leaves of durable oh actually so
we're getting to something interesting
here uh so the parakana
and incidentally none of these four
tribes that she was looking at are any
that we have um spent any time with we
haven't we don't
i didn't at least didn't know any of
them by name the parakana are
specialists on terrestrial game in
particular land tortoises
tapir peccaries which is wild pigs
armadillo and
paca which is a big rodent they report
they are most interested in eating
tapirs however whereas both the arara
and the arawete say that they avoid
eating tapers whenever possible
so they didn't get a lot of tapers when
she was there observing them and
instantly she took in all of her own
food which is pretty rare for cultural
antipolishes but she took in all of her
own food
in order not she brought in food she
brought in all of her own food
to prevent the local people from
um either hiding food that they found
particularly precious they didn't want
to share with her so that she would get
a skewed vision of what she was eating
um and to avoid um basically changing
how much they needed such that they had
to hunt more and thus change the
fractional composition of what they're
eating so really well done again all
right who were these people
uh those were the parakana who
specialized in terrestrial game and
these are in um
in um this is in the brazilian amazon
okay
so and they avoid eating tapir no
oh yes sorry yes yep no no no no they
prefer eating tapir
and the arara and the arawete
avoiding avoid eating tape i must say
there is
no job on earth easier than avoiding
eating tapir
given how skittish and hard to find this
animal is it's really
it's amazingly easy not to eat tapir if
you're hunting all of your own food
and so for those who don't know tapirs
are
big they're really big and one tapio
could feed
a village for a while yeah but if it's
not your thing i mean you're not going
to find yourself
accidentally consuming a tape here it
just that's probably true
oops i killed a tape here gotta eat it
yeah yep
nope um okay the arawete
uh again uh brazilian amazonian people
specialize on large birds including
macaws and toucans
right um plus okay
too can i can almost see but not only do
they specialize in your macaws
but they have macaws as pets their
villages are filled with pet macaws
and their diet is leaning heavily
towards macaws that they are catching
wild and eating
catching while but not raising not
raising interest
what do those pat mccaws think macaws
are freaking smart they have theory of
my them and
and and uh i want to see kobits corvids
like the crows and jays are incredibly
smart social long-lived generational
overlap
all of this they must be appalled so
they are
democrats feeding yes yes they are
feeding these macaws
the pets presumably i don't know maybe
not i i
understood you to suggest that they were
um catching
and raising for food these may cause or
is it
there's pets they're hunting macaws and
eating them and then they also have
peppercorns they also have pet macaws
that they never eat
so apparently you know this is this is
almost a throwaway line in this paper
um that i found i was unable to track
down further but
you know the author here milton who
again seems to have been doing really
careful work
back in 1992's when it was published um
lived in the villages with each of these
tribes for some period of time and
you know was was a careful observer and
cultural anthropologist
and usually a primatologist
um oh also the arawete unlike all three
of the other tribes that she's uh
looking at have no dogs and they have no
desire for dogs when asked they say why
would we have dogs whereas all the other
three tribes are largely
have dogs and use dogs to help them hunt
and when you say dogs are you talking
about domestic dogs are you talking
about forest dogs that they have
domesticated i believe
she doesn't specify but i believe we're
talking about domestic dogs given what
we've seen
in um yeah and that would be a modern
change
sure yeah yep exactly um oh one more
thing the araweta apparently also have
45 different classifications for not
snow
as as you might imagine but i would
imagine they have none right they don't
have a word for snow i'm making that up
but probably not
they have 45 different classifications
and i don't know if classifications
means words or what
for honey hmm that makes perfect sense
oh man in an environment like that where
you have so many different source plants
um yeah and age and a lot of different
species of bees although most of the
bees aren't going to be making honey
yeah yeah yeah but there are more i mean
there's it's not just apis maleficent i
think that makes that
is going to be making uh honey is it
it's apis it's other apuses
uh i don't know i am
on that i would have said maybe it is
but um but i don't know
okay um or you know really the question
is make enough honey to be worth
pursuing
right um yeah a solitary b is not going
to be yeah
we're worth pursuing um
so finally we have the mayaruna who are
actually in the peruvian amazon
um who specialize in peccaries but they
state that they prefer eating tapirs and
sloths
even though tapers and slots are harder
for them to find and most of their diet
consists of peccaries
and this is a little there's a little
violent so you know close your ears if
you don't want to hear how they
how they deal with the sloths when they
find them quote sloths are captured by
climbing their tree
lassoing them with a noose made of vines
pulling them free and then clubbing them
to death on the ground
that's this that's the sloth killing
activity yeah um
and while she was there probably a lot
more humane than
you know what other option do you have
yeah i mean you could you know you could
do shoot them out of the tree and have
them fall that ain't going to be a fun
death yeah
which is uh you know how how at least
some uh like this at least how the
lorani um
hunt um yeah um and oh instantly
spinning the morani
milton the wahrani who are people whom
we have spent time
around and with in the ecuadorean amazon
um she points out that the diet of the
mayaruna or the people i was just
talking about actually most closely
matches that of the wahrani
so that is that is that is more similar
to something that we have known
um the mayaruna have the longest list of
foods that they will not eat
of any of the tribes she looked at and
here we go
some that are developmental stage
specific so for specifically with regard
to howler monkeys
adult marijuana do not eat higher
monkeys but children do
wow that's exactly the opposite of what
i would predict right why
uh because howler monkeys are obligate
folivores
and the toxins are liable to be more
dangerous to a developing
child or a pregnant woman in fact there
is a lot of anecdotal stuff and i
believe a certain amount of
data to suggest that um
aversions during pregnancy may be about
protecting fetuses and things so
um anyway i would have expected an
obligate full of or
a to taste really terrible in a
landscape like the amazon where there's
so many species
and the obligate folivares themselves
are sampling from a wide variety of
yes and they're eating where they're
taking in the secondary compounds of the
plants
that have produced those secondary
compounds in order to protect themselves
right
right
exactly so anyway um yeah what is the
explanation for uh
yeah i don't know lots lots of little
juicy stuff in here right
and some not so juicy stuff including
macaws
yeah which uh charles handley he didn't
specifically
tell me about mccos but he told me he
was uh
a uh the great batman of the uh
smithsonian
who was one of your mentors a mentor of
mine on bci
um and uh anyway i've forgotten
why he found himself eating parrot at
some point
but he uh he reported that
it was a lot like eating a shoe
[Laughter]
so i'm guessing macaws are rather like
that yeah no i have um
i may actually have less interest if i
had to choose if i was starving i had to
choose between monkey and parrot i
really don't want to have to ever eat
either but yeah um
oh monkey yeah stands a good chance of
being not just for
not just for edibility actually oh i get
there i don't want to eat a monkey
because it's a monkey but
from the point of view of what would the
meat taste like except for
howlers which are the exception all
those frugivores probably taste just
fine
yeah yeah um and the peccaries surely
taste good
yeah i mean if you like bacon you
probably like peccaries it's a pig i bet
it's a lot leaner
but um and also you know tapirs
might you're convinced
yeah because because they're giant
ground dwellers so they're in part i
mean
the intact amazon doesn't have much to
graze per se but the browsing at ground
level
um is um i think
i mean maybe just because there's a lot
of new growth that they're going to be
able to access and the new growth has
fewer secondary compounds
yeah but they eat a lot of fruit too
yeah
and the thing that is most famously
delicious
are um the uh paca
the pakkas and a goodies they're
supposed to be absolutely delicious yeah
those are those are big big rodents yep
and um and you know
pakis are mentioned once here goodies
are never mentioned in capybara never
mentioned
but i imagine that the large
slow somewhat dim ground-dwelling
rodents get hunted out
pretty quickly yep yeah yeah that would
be
likely yeah and i'm gonna i'm gonna
catch it from all of the capybara
enthusiasts out there for calling them
dim but sorry compared to
most other things on this list they are
yeah yeah
all right um so um from the discussion
i'm just gonna read a couple more of
the things that she has written yet
beyond very general and obvious
environmental differences
none of the environmental factors i
examined appeared sufficiently distinct
to explain most of the dietary
differences observed
here we go here she is repeating um in
different language the hypothesis that
she leads with
which i didn't share with you guys yet
these different dietary practices appear
to reflect
as do the distinctive facial
perforations and body decorations of
each group
a type of cultural character
displacement in which the members of
group a
seek to differentiate themselves from
members of group b or c by means that
are distinctive
but do not pose any actual economic
disadvantage
and this this struck me as interesting
in part for her choice of the term
character displacement which i think we
probably need to define here
which i might have called niche
partitioning right so i was going to
point out that very connection
yeah so so these are two terms from
ecology basically
um character displacement referring to
two
closely related organisms that um are
often sympatric
or or adjacent to simpatric um
one of whom begins to change its actual
characteristics
in order to inhabit a different space in
order to make
make use of a different resource whereas
niche partitioning
refers to finding a different niche in
which to
inhabit so as not in both cases it's
about avoiding direct competition
with a close relative who would be a
very close competitor
yeah i would say one is the evolutionary
consequence of the other yeah
so character displacement being the
evolutionary consequence of niche
partitioning but
niche partitioning is also an
evolutionary process
right but so i when you describe this to
me
i thought that the hypothesis was going
to be about people living very close to
each other
engaged in partitioning and resulting in
character displacement
sounds to me like these people are
sufficiently
separated well um let me know let me see
if i'm
gonna doubt the hypothesis uh if i'm if
i'm
right in interpreting it that way yeah
let me you you keep going i
unfortunately have turned my well so my
left side here
what it sounds to me like
uh you just read from that abstract
that was the discussion from the
discussion is the
argument that the
specific preferences and aversions of
these groups carry
no cost and therefore
as a matter of culturally separating
oneself
you know that it is star bellies versus
no stars
but here's what i doubt i doubt that in
isolation
that these could be low enough cost
choices
to be arbitrary in other words anything
that you
fail to hunt because those people eat it
and we we wouldn't dare
right anything that you turn down is a
cost
well except that for instance the
the group that that specializes on large
birds
and doesn't have dogs um is presumably
not as good
at hunting for instance tapir and agudi
precisely because the dogs would help
and the dogs are a hindrance in hunting
birds i
100 agree with you but then what you
would expect
is that the um specialization
would be whatever is optimal over time
it will move towards the
optimal diet for that habitat
independent of what anybody else does
right if the populations are close
together
then you could decide we don't need a
goodie and we therefore specialize on
parrots and the reason would be if we
hunt a goodie and you hunt a goodie
we're going to
drive them extinct here and so you could
have like a cryptic partnership where
by not hunting the same stuff that your
neighbors
uh eat your habitat fuels
their access to resource and their
habitat fuels your access to resource
and you know nobody has to formally um
exchange anything but if these are large
enough geographic regions which it
sounds like they are
well i mean if if you would let us show
the map of her
here this is uh the this is the
this is northern south america in white
we have brazil
uh ecuador is off the west edge here but
we've got the brazilian amazon with the
two main states para
and amazonas and the circles
here this is i'm going to scroll up just
a little bit this is the arara people
the parakana the arawete they're all
really close together
oh i wouldn't call that close and um
then the maruna
are in fact quite distinct and they're
over closer to irani territory yeah as i
mentioned
so i think the argument i'm making
is that in order for that hypothesis to
be right
this has to be effectively within home
range
distance for the animals in question
right and absent that what i would argue
is that you've got
specialization on whatever the optimal
diet is you got
specialization because you know to the
extent that you're a generalist you'll
hunt everything badly so you'll
specialize on that which is particularly
huntable in your habitat for whatever
reason your diet will
move you know as there's difference you
know somebody prefers this bird somebody
prefers that bird the bird that's
the highest roi will you know
come to dominate the diet anyway you get
this evolution towards the optimal diet
for your local habitat and
then what i would argue is you will get
the tendency to view those other people
the rare cases of an encounter and their
weird dietary preferences
as you know an indication of their
inferiority or
distinction or whatever but that it
can't be driven
by niche partitioning at that scale i
just
it's too far for you know maybe in the
case of
some very far flighted birds but other
than that
it seems unlikely i don't think that you
have
falsified her hypothesis based on the
point locations of the particular
villages that she went through
we need we need to see the actual
territorial
uh delineations of where these tribes
exist the mayaruna
are farther afield like they're far west
which apparently is that way today
yeah in fact it's that way um and
farther south from here at the moment
but the other three tribes
um she chose i believe in part because
uh the historical anthropological
understanding which is obviously nowhere
close to the full
lifespan of these peoples is that they
were
that they were neighbors yep um and and
i'm not sure if they still are
okay so this is why you tune in to the
dark horse podcast and not all of the
other podcasts that talk about the
rainforest dietary choices right because
here
you get the hypothesis with the
prediction
now if i am right about the causal
mechanism here
then what you will see is the tendency
towards this
dietary specialization to increase at
the borders between
and that you will find that those
populations in each of these groups that
are very far from those borders are much
less picky and
you know belly perfect right love this
yeah yeah so that's great
there it is that's excellent all right
shall we move on why don't we why don't
we move on
um
yeah let's talk about oh boy i can't
find anything on my computer at the
moment
because it's not organized the way it
was supposed to be um
the vaccine which we spent a lot of time
talking about
a little bit a few episodes ago i'm just
going to keep talking until i can find
this thing which is not coming up
here we go and it's so tiny um
let's see nope
the organ oh boy okay
can you start talking for a minute while
i find this nothing about the computer
is quite working today
all right yes i'm going to start talking
about vaccines
vaccine derives from the term vodka
okay good lord um so
um the oregon coronavirus update letter
i get on email
uh every every weekday i think and
two of the most recent ones
had such weird errors or
claims that it reminded me
once again of how politicized this
landscape is and why if you are trying
to think for yourself
you are likely throwing up your hands in
dismay at
all of the scolds telling you you
absolutely must not take a vaccine or
you absolutely must take a vaccine
because obviously science says
obviously science doesn't say because um
those
proc those blanket proclamations are are
ridiculous
so i can't pull up a screenshot for you
guys but i'm going to read from the
oregon coronavirus update letter from
december 28th which says the oregon
department of veterans affairs
announced today that residents and staff
at its oregon veterans homes in lebanon
and the dalles
received their first dose of the um of
the pfizer covet 19 vaccine
from consensus healthcare over the
weekend vaccinations were made available
to all staff and residents
the vaccine has been proclaimed safe and
affected by scientists and health
professionals including a four-state
scientific safety review group comprised
of experts from oregon
california washington and nevada
allow me to repeat the the phrase the
vaccine has been
proclaimed safe and effective by
scientists and health professionals this
is a scientific proclamation
it's a scientific proclamation because
that is the way that science is done
by raised by a show of hands by a desire
to move forward not
by hypothesis and prediction and
data collection and analysis certainly
not no it's by proclamation it's by fiat
in fact it's science by fiat well when i
ascend the position of extreme
actually unlimited power it will no
longer be done by proclamation it will
be done by
encyclical encyclical encyclical yes we
will issue
scientific encyclicals and in fact
nature will be forced to abide by them
nature at the magazine of the nature of
the process is outside there
yeah exactly so um
boy then we have this i guess you can
show this zachary
um from yesterday the same the same
email newsletter from january 1st 2021
case of severe allergic reaction to
coveted 19 reported in walawa
individuals employed at memorial
hospital and recovering
and it goes on and on and on and in the
first paragraph it does say oh actually
it's not a severe allergic reaction to
cover 19
it's a severe allergic reaction to the
modernity vaccine for covet 19.
in fact the headline the subject of this
email the headline of this email
says there's been a severe allergic
reaction to a disease which makes no
sense it makes no more sense the idea
that combo is a vaccination for anything
right
this is this is presumably in this case
not intentional not intentional
politicization of science it's just
complete incompetence because this is
not a mere copyrighted
error it completely renders this entire
thing meaningless
well i i would bet it's you know it's
beyond
an error i would bet that somebody
having been browbeaten into the belief
that these things are good and those
things are
bad right did not
internalize the message here which is
vaccine
cause severe allergic reaction that's a
very dangerous phenomenon i thought
vaccines were good and so some part of
them
probably made that error because it
resolved a cognitive dissonance
yeah i mean in fact the fact that
someone
experienced a severe allergic reaction
from vaccine
that's going to happen no matter what
the vaccine is all you know
any anything will is likely any medicine
is likely to cause
some allergic reaction some extreme
reactions perhaps even some fatalities
in some people
and that's terrible and also true and
also says
very little about the overall efficacy
or safety of that
of that thing but when you have the
report on it
which conveniently disappears the
salient term yeah
um you are left to wonder what it is
that you are supposed to believe
right in fact what a vaccine does is
almost
literally create an allergic reaction to
the pathogen
that's how it works that's that's when a
vaccine is working appropriately
and we don't talk about it in those
terms but that is effectively what is
going on so the whole thing
turns to gobbledygook if you try to
morally sort
the logic and you know write your titles
based on it
yeah um yeah so
gobbledygook for some reason
gobbledygook for some reason um
you want to talk about uh some of the
other treatments for
covert that are out there you want to
talk about let's talk a little bit about
uh them zach are you able to show things
that i
sent you or um
so uh unfortunately we're a little
discombobulated here because
okay can you show the
um the piece
on uh ramdessavir
and that's that um
[Music]
that's not
okay so this is a piece that was
forwarded to me
by a good friend and what it does
actually i don't no one including me
knows which piece you're talking about
yet the piece on your screen there which
is now up
so the argument here is that the policy
in the u.s in particular the policy in
the u.s
appears to be um to basically
convalesce in place if you contract
covid
until you are sick enough to go to the
hospital at which point we deploy
various remedies and the position that
this
journalist takes is that in fact this is
an absurd response because what we have
which americans are largely unaware of
is a large
uh body of information
about treatments that are highly
effective at reducing
harm both preventing people from getting
covered and
reducing the harm when they do get
covered and that this has somehow
fallen by the wayside and i will argue
that this is because
what we have is a system in which our
narrative surrounding everything
has been politicized and um
that this has resulted in basically
uh a run-of-the-mill kind of corruption
that causes the narrative to be bent to
various people's
desires and this is not only affecting
our discussion about
vaccines which we will get to shortly
but it is directly affecting
both the policy surrounding when we
treat people in other words do we wait
till you're sick and have to go to the
hospital
or do we treat you up front and
basically the argument is
if you're somebody very important you're
going to get medical treatment right
away
we will treat you with things that work
and
you will miraculously have a mild case
but if you are
a commoner you will get very very sick
before that happens or you will recover
and so the argument here is that
remdesseviere which is the
gold standard in standard channels is
actually
not a very effective drug at all it is
um at best mildly effective reduces the
course of infection by a couple of days
but it's expensive it does have that
going forward it does have that going
for it
uh um whereas
ervermectin uh irvamectin vermectin yeah
appears to be highly effective
it is a drug with a long safety record i
was going to read
so yeah i've got i have a couple here
that i wanted you want to read something
yeah
maybe it won't be the same thing you
would found but maybe it will be um
so you can show it if you want zack you
don't have to um just
one paragraph early on not directly
related to what you were talking about
but this fixed fixed narrative has led
youtube twitter and facebook to practice
a new and insidious form of censorship
under the dictum that emerging studies
are fatally flawed and fostered by
fringe elements uh quote there's no
evidence that ivermectin has been proven
a safe or effective treatment against
covet 19
declared an associated press
fact-checking article similar reports
regurgitate government pronouncements
that journalism at its best
ought rather question and then down
below
um we have this section on invermecton
three paragraphs i'm going to read in a
20 excuse me in a 2011 article the
scientist who discovered ivermectin in
1975
in a patch of japanese soil satoshi
omora
called it astonishingly safe and quote a
wonder drug
akin to penicillin and aspirin after
more than 25 years of use a review in
the journal of drugs and dermatology
concluded
if vermectin continues to provide a high
margin of safety
but the u.s federal excuse me but the
u.s food and drug administration seems
bent on ignoring both safety and
efficacy findings
in a q a on avermectin the agency lists
side effects from nausea and swelling to
neurological events and liver injury
flcccc president dr pierre cory
described the list for me as
quote purposefully alarmist indeed
despite more than 40 positive studies in
avermectin for kovid
the fda seems stuck in a time warp its
website calls the australian study from
eight months ago recently released while
still declaring without acknowledging
newer studies
that additional testing is needed that's
fine if only there was support
just three studies in ivermectin are
proceeding in the united states and none
is funded by the national institute of
health or any other u.s agency
yeah i find this absolutely stunning
here's another section i thought was
pretty remarkable
for 25 years vermectin has been
distributed free in 19 african countries
to control
parasites is it a coincidence that those
countries had
28 fewer coveted deaths and 8 percent
fewer cases than 35
other african nations is it a
coincidence that the 240
million resident uh indian state of
uttar
tardes which distributes free ivermectin
has a coveted
uh death rate that is 1 16th that of the
united states
160th sorry i'm reading very small font
yeah it is um so are those things
conclusive they are not because you have
an uncontrolled environment but they are
certainly provocative
um see there was another section i
wanted to
ivermectin the most promising covet
treatment to date won its developers the
nobel prize for medicine in 2015 and a
place in the world health organization's
model list of essential medicines since
the 1980s with billions of doses given
the drug has cured crippling tropical
diseases
that have devastated african countries
while curbing scabies
lice and protecting livestock and dogs
from parasites spurred by pre-coveted
studies showing ivermectin killed
zika and other viruses australian
researchers last spring
tested the drug in a petri dish where it
obliterated coronavice
virus in 48 hours since then more than
three dozen studies have shown good
results in preventing and treating
covid19 to be sure some of the results
sound too good to be true and are based
on small patient samples
others are available only in online
drafts and have not been officially
published
but 16 studies have been peer reviewed
and 11
are randomized controlled trials that
compared patients who did
and did not get the drug so that is all
very provocative
now it sure is what i believe is
emerging and i don't know quite how to
cast it has nothing to do
with ivermectin and remdesavir
uh or vaccines in particular is a more
general
malady where before you do that can we
just finish
this off before you go into more general
malady this paper that you were just
reading from
uh links to this site zach and it is
called uh
it's it's just a coveted 19 um basically
clearing house site uh which uh is
done anonymously um
let's see i had found
the facts before i don't see them here
oh here frequently asked questions about
this site um
says we're a bunch of researchers who
aren't interested in
going public but we are basically just
putting together evidence for a number
of
a number of different drugs that are
currently being used to treat this is
not about
the vaccines it's about drugs for
treatment rather than vaccines for
prevention
and their their collated information
on every macdon here shows um
tremendously and i'm not this is a
complicated page i'm not going to walk
us through what it is
um but this this page is still up c19
every mectin.com
and you can go through you know efficacy
across lots of studies of vivremectin
vitamin d hydroxychloroquine
zinc and remdesseviere which has much
lower efficacy
but interestingly and
fairly appallingly um what we
find is um
[Music]
i now can't find the site that oh here
we go
um twitter suspended the account
that was being used to um to basically
publicize this work
at covet analysis on december 27th
and there's no explanation or response
from twitter
as to why what exactly on this page is
dangerous
it is a it is a collation of
extant research on a number of possible
treatments for the scourge
that is threatening to wipe out people
and
economics across the entire world what
exactly is so dangerous about this
right and why does twitter think that it
is expert enough to decide whether or
not we are able to look at this and
discuss it
right who the hell are they yeah and so
the site is still up but the twitter
account is not
yeah so you were sorry yeah what i
wanted to argue
is that what we have what we find
evidence for across the board
anywhere where we take the narrative
that we are handed
and we scrutinize it with tools that we
happen to have
because we're biologists right obviously
we're not
epidemiologists we're not virology
specialists
right but the point is basic scientific
literacy a willingness to dive into
these things what we find again and
again is that the narrative that we are
being handed and the narrative we see
being enforced
on social media is itself garbage and
politicized and one can deduce
what its purpose is by virtue of the
fact that clearly
it is willing to harm people
in order to keep the message simple
and on track in other words why all else
being equal why would the narrative
center
around remdesseviere a drug that has
um dubious effectiveness and
systematically shun ivermectin
when the safety and efficacy appears to
suggest exactly the reverse would be
wise that that is a preposterous thing
for it to do and the
obvious result is that people will be
harmed right we should be thinking about
treating covid
treating covet is almost certainly a
good way to prevent people from
communicating covid
and so you know there's no way in which
this is responsible or if it is somehow
responsible
why are we not allowed to have the
discussion that then will inevitably
reach that conclusion because we will
discover the reason that rem desevere is
the right choice
and even if even if these two drugs
impromectant and rem desevere
had exactly the same results in the
variety of research that's been done
with regard to treating symptoms of
copen19
the fact that it's ivermectin
that has been around that is discovered
in japanese soil in the 1970s apparently
and has been used in millions of people
for other conditions
and therefore has a decades-long
history of studies of safety of places
where it's not presumably
we should prefer that drug all else
being equal
over a newer one just as if there
is a vaccine that is made in the
traditional style
that is available all else being equal
we should prefer
that over an mrna vaccine simply because
there is no way proclamations from
scientists notwithstanding
to know whether or not the new
technology is safe yet we simply cannot
know
right we the public right we who are
united against covet and its
transmission ought to prefer that on the
other hand there's a
very small group that might have exactly
the opposite incentive oh gee
who could they be well and we see this
all the time in pharmaceutical
development where basically
patent protection expires on a drug and
some
new either a new drug that isn't any
better is introduced because
it's patented it's got a little more tax
week has been made
in order to make these things more
profitable and the fact is
this is just a place where markets do a
piss-poor job of managing
the public health um so anyway we see
this all over the place and you
um so i don't know what the patent
situation
is for ivermecton given that description
of how long it's been around
probably uh cheap and uh
readily you know generics available and
just you know just
one other line of evidence to support
that is if it is really being deployed
at the millions of people level across
africa
it's it's probably not a super expensive
drug
to be to be producing or to be giving
out excellent point and the other thing
is
it has generated exactly the natural
experiments
that would allow you to deduce pattern
in other words the fact that you've got
a bunch of different
african countries you know i think it
was 18 of them had
widespread and 30 some odd that didn't
that allows you
doesn't mean that that's why the 18 seem
to outperform the 30-some
but it's a strong indication and that
itself is a testable hypothesis so
there's lots of
there's lots of landscape to look at in
order to figure out what is actually
going on and what it
says about what we should do yeah um all
right so should we move on to the uh
the vaccine question here oh okay
what do you got well i thought we'd
already done it no we we did the
the rem de severe versus
okay so um the last thing zach could you
show
the like did i just say we want to hit
ted wheeler before we did
say that yeah i might amount that we're
we are
we are peaceful people um i want you to
show
the new york times piece on the
astrazeneca
oxford vaccine yeah okay so oh
i cannot really show it on the other
screen um there we go thank you
so in any case what we've got here is a
situation with the vaccines that is far
more interesting and in which there is
far more for us to discuss
than i believe we realize so we have two
first-past-the-post vaccines of this
very new type
this mrna vaccine
platform which is untested in humans
which has only been around
tested in humans for the last nine or so
months
and then we have a third vaccine so
those are
the the makers of those with which are
the names with which people will be
familiar are pfizer
and moderna right right okay so the fiso
modern vaccines
are separately created mrna vaccines
which is a new vaccine technology
which the advantage of which is they can
actually be
developed in like a weekend apparently
um
whereas traditional vaccines tend to
take a lot longer but you can't but
okay but we have no safety record right
of
their long-term implications we have no
concept of how they interface they're
extremely expensive to deploy because of
the need for extreme refrigeration
etc so um anyway
i feel like we shouldn't have to say
this every time but because we're going
to get clipped again and again
being called anti-vaxxers and all of
this garbage
let us hope that these mrna vaccines are
what they promise to be this is an
entirely new
mechanism for delivering vaccines
and it is quite possible that these will
be lower side effect
better and because they're rapidly
deployable this may be the answer to
some of humanity's greatest new problems
which involve emerging new viruses
either
bioterrorism or who knows what else
copen19 won't be the last if mrna
vaccines are
effective and safe that could be the way
that we survive the emerging
viruses and even perhaps viral
bioweapons that could be emerging
right right so you and i are rooting for
these vaccines that would be an awesome
addition to our uh antivirus quiver
really hope so right on the other hand
frightening
that we are going to deploy these at
such large scale with some of the most
important people in society in the midst
of a pandemic
without properly investigating
or properly considering what it means to
deploy something
on which we have no long-term data on
the safety we don't know if these cause
something
you know months or years years down the
road
so actually let me say that if if these
mrna vaccines
uh five years down the road do um
do prove to have been safe safe-ish
relatively safe you know there will
always be some some problems right if
they do
relatively harmless okay relatively
harmless and
a new virus emerges and a
mrna vaccine is produced very quickly to
deal with that virus
we would not sound the same way about
that mrna vaccine as we do about this
one
now there are still concerns with any
brand new vaccine that doesn't have
a a long period of safety testing but
just as i believe
where you're going to go here with
regard to the oxford astrozeneca vaccine
is that that is a
traditional vaccine is that right yes
and
without knowing anything more than that
about it
i prefer that one simply because the
traditional
way that we have been developing
vaccines has
problems for sure but we have
decades we have many many decades of
safety testing and efficacy testing and
all of this
on this route by which to end up with
vaccines
you and i are more vaccinated than just
about anyone else we know because of the
time we've spent in the tropics
all of this and that like yes
at the moment because we don't have the
the history on mrna vaccines we are
concerned about what we don't know but
if it is a class of vaccines that has
five or ten years behind it at that
point every new vaccine that is trotted
out
in that uh with that technology will
will cause less concern it should cause
less concern it should cause less
concern
and so there's a question we now have a
third vaccine emerging slightly later
it has what should be several things
about it that should cause us to
strongly prefer it
one is it's a normal vaccine that
doesn't require extreme
refrigeration so it's easily deployed
it's
uh comparatively cheap and astrazeneca
who has teamed up with oxford to
generate this thing has agreed
to have it be profitless
for i don't know what the period is but
for an extended period of time
so they've offered it uh into the the
public space
um i think it's i think it's three bucks
a dose or something like that it's very
inexpensive
um we have the emails oh yeah it's like
250 a dose
if if deployed by the government ten
dollars a dose if if privately
acquired something like that right now
very
interesting fact about it so you will
hear
reported everywhere that it's much less
effective at preventing covet
now this makes an error in two ways one
we don't
really know what the mrna vaccines um
are doing in fact there is caution in
some circles about the fact that it may
be that people who have been vaccinated
with these mrna vaccines are still
perfectly capable of transmitting
cloven to other people they just don't
show symptoms as the idea or that
they never show up as having tested
positive somehow somehow
so i i don't expect it will i expect we
will find that it does prevent the
disease and right people
don't therefore transmit we don't have
but we don't have that data it's all too
new
yeah but in this case you will see well
okay those
mrna vaccines are 90 or more percent
effective
um astrazeneca's unfortunately is only
uh
60 some percent effective but get this
well but actually the second sentence
here
says a clinical trial revealed the
vaccine was up to 90 effective you know
why
why they made an error in the test we
did
those who were doing the testing okay
okay in
in this welcome to complex systems folks
they made an error in which they
accidentally halved the dose
right so they ran an experiment they
didn't mean to run
and they now have data comparing what
they thought was the full dose
which has something like 60
effectiveness and half the dose which
has
90 effectiveness very much like these
mrna vaccines right
so okay a why does that happen an
inadvertent experiment
that also runs exactly counter to what
you would expect and makes you wonder
how is it
that the people who developed a vaccine
decide on the dosage in the first place
well
right and doesn't it just say that what
we ought to be doing one of the things
we ought to be doing is figuring out you
know whatever the mechanism is that we
figure
out what a dose is and whether or not
you need two of them we need to vary a
lot of stuff in order to figure out
did we miss it because we you know we're
10 times over the magic number
right right um you know and in lots of
cases
we've seen stuff like that um so anyway
the point is
okay so it turns out that the most
effective dose is probably half
what we thought or maybe it gets even
better if you cut it below that who
knows yeah
right wouldn't that be good news um
right so why does it happen we don't
know i sort of have a guess
which is if you think about it so is it
is this also a two dose vaccine like the
mrna vaccine yes so it's a half so the
idea is it was
up to 90 effective when it was a half
dose to start and then a full dose for
the second one
if if memory serves yeah i think that's
right but so anyway i was going to take
a guess
and i was going to say one of the things
that you and i puzzled over at length
on early live streams was the fact that
the thing that you see in the textbook
about how a virus gets you
doesn't predict the fact that there's
like a threshold dose
that briefly passing through a room in
which some very
coveted sick person has been exhaling
probably doesn't get you sick but if you
spend a few minutes there it probably
will so there's something
that fills up there's some non-specific
immunity
that gets overwhelmed and at the point
that it gets overwhelmed a virus does
what's in the textbook it invades your
cell
and starts replicating right but until
then
the non-specific stuff is probably good
enough at clearing the garbage without
recognizing it so your prediction here
is that at the
higher dose it's actually making people
sick right that it's basically
so what this is what this vaccine sells
that's totally consistent with other
vaccines right it's
you need you need to trigger your immune
system to recognize and develop the
right response
without triggering it so much that you
get full full-blown whatever it is the
diseases
you won't get full-blown you won't get
the disease from the vaccine no matter
what
but the test was if you get the vaccine
right are you vulnerable if you
encounter somebody with covet so scroll
up if you can sorry i did not mean to
imply no it's okay
keep going
keep going all right so here
you've got this um adenovirus
vaccine this is the astrazeneca oxford
vaccine
it enters the cell and it does a much
more standard thing
than the mrna vaccines the mrna vaccines
bypass
the nucleus and what they do is they
dump
mrna into the system which ribosomes
then transcribe
into proteins that then get displayed to
the immune system
in this case you have this virus this
harmless virus introduce
dna with the proper information in it
into the nucleus in a standard way
the nucleus then transcribes it into
mrna which then
does effectively the same thing from
there that the mrna vaccines do so keep
scrolling up so let me just say that the
only reason that this
feels less science fictiony than the
mrna vaccines
is because we've been doing this for
decades already it has inherently moved
from the realm of science fiction to
science fact
decades ago and the mrna vaccines moved
from science fiction to science fact
in 2020 and therefore we don't know what
all is downstream yep um
so anyway the hypothesis that we are
playing with here
which again this is not our area of
expertise but just based on everything
that we've talked about with respect to
threshold doses and the like
the possibility of the reason that a
higher dose gained
lower effectiveness is that there's some
fraction of the immune system
that is capable of recognizing particles
that look something like the spike
protein
of sars cov2 and if you gum them up
with these viral particles with these uh
vaccine particles these vaccine
generated particles that it may
paradoxically open up the chance that a
covid particle that you encounter
in the wild can get by because they're
all gummed up
so anyway
um so anyway it's a testable hypothesis
which is what we like
um and uh you know so
that predicts things about uh the
curve that you would see for various
dosages
yeah right that effectively higher would
give you
lower effectiveness to some point
because it would effectively gum up all
the works but
okay so back to the point here we got
three vaccines
two of them are in a totally novel
platform
and therefore carry what you and i have
described as
high risk which does not mean high harm
it means we don't know what happens long
term when you've had this and things on
the list probably uh
include things like um autoimmune
disorders
that will give you an autoimmune
disorder no idea hopefully not by risk
because high uncertainty because high
uncertainty exactly and
we have seen a bunch of stuff in the
article that we covered
a couple of live streams ago about the
um very poor reporting on
the side effects of the mrna vaccines
ought to loom large here too
people are getting very serious
reactions sometimes to these things
but anyway in a universe where you've
got three vaccines
two of which are of this very
extraordinary new type
that come with high risk because high
uncertainty one of which is on
a uh familiar platform it's still
new but we know a lot about it because a
lot of it isn't new
right the basic virus that delivers the
thing isn't new
and so this is the one i want right
and it is being portrayed as much less
effective
even if it was 60 effective i think i
still prefer this one
you know and why is that is astrazeneca
not an american company like what what
british
well actually i don't want to say it's
british i think it is but oxford
certainly
right uh is a british institution yeah
and uh
you know we just we put oh the u.s
we put so much of our funding to
um vaccine development and not to
treatment
not to these other other drugs and
also you know it won't be if we're right
that astrazeneca
having signed up with oxford indicates
that it's not an american company
much of those the return on investment
would be far lower for the in-house in
american house developed vaccines
if people start preferring the
traditionally developed vaccine that
came from outside the country
at the very least we ought to be
discussing you know the cost
of a dose is very different the
architecture you need to deliver the
dose is very different
rural areas already exists here we ought
to be discussing
okay we're going to give it to all uh
of the medical personnel right makes
sense to protect medical personnel
can we give a quarter of them or half of
them
this is the other one in case there's
something we don't know
i mean that obviously makes sense right
so the point is you've got any any
demographic population any
demographically described population
should get a mixture if we are going to
continue to learn
not any combination but some people in
that demographic should get one of these
types of vaccines and some should get
the other and then those results should
be tracked
so the disturbing conclusion i think
from the
last little thing where we talked about
the comparison between two drugs where
the world seems to have concluded the
opposite of
what would make sense yeah the
comparison here between these vaccine
technologies
the nonsensical discussion early on
about
face masks the nonsensical discussion we
are now having about face masks where
outdoors people are still uh looking at
each other as morally deficient for
not wearing them i got into a thing on
that this week i won't go there now
the discussion that we are having about
lockdown
and the inability seemingly of anybody
in charge of policy to
juggle the various costs of lockdown
versus not lockdown
all of these discussions are
as far as i can tell complete garbage
one afternoon with five smart people
and decent information would cause a
radically different
policy decision yep then we are being
fed so what we've got is just some
narrative
generated some way now either it's
generated
through incompetence or it is
corrupt which i think is more likely
where at every little stage of the
project i think we're lucky enough to
have both
yeah well undoubtedly the uh
incompetence is a feature not a bug from
the point of view of the corrupters
yeah but it is amazing i think
how far we are likely underperforming
by virtue of the fact that on you know
that what drug you're going to take
and when you're going to take it has
apparently been politicized right can
you think of something that could
possibly be a less political question
right um so i don't know what we're
going to do about this
but the whole narrative surrounding
covid which should unite us
we should have our very best people
coming up with the very
highest quality insights they would no
doubt make mistakes and they should be
pushed back against them
and no amount of pushback should be read
as a political maneuver
right that their work shouldn't be
political or politicized
and the criticisms and uh trying to
figure out if they're actually saying
what they think they're saying and all
of that
shouldn't be read as political either
right this is this is what science is
supposed to do and we should be
discussing this
on twitter and youtube and
every other place without fear of being
thrown off the platform for having
violated these sacred conclusions or
being placed into your tribal
affiliation on the basis of whether or
not you
are wearing a mask when you're outside
or are questioning whether or not to
take the new vaccine
or are a hundred percent gonna take it
no matter what and you're willing to
call people dummies if they don't
yeah you know none of this is smart
any any of those responses is
you know at at best dim and at worst as
you said
corrupt and corrupting yeah so just
think about how
different the prescription looks if you
just sort of
look at these analyses you know these
analyses could be wrong maybe we've seen
the wrong stuff and there's more
compelling stuff elsewhere but if this
stuff is right
then the answer is don't close your
state parks and other stuff encourage
people to spend as much time outdoors as
possible because
among other things vitamin d and they
won't lose their minds okay
so that's good vitamin d won't lose your
mind those are two protective things
um if you get sick with covid
uh you probably uh want ivermectin and
you want it right away rather than
waiting to see if you get super sick
and from the point of view of
vaccinating people we've got
some new technologies which are
promising we've got a tried and true one
which is
uh also rapidly developed incredibly
impressive there
and may be equally as effective much
cheaper
right so at least some of us are easier
to deploy
easier to deploy some of us ought to be
getting that one instead and maybe
the fact is we should be trying to get
that to as many people as possible
because it's a better bet
right um so that's a you know that's
like
not radical except in an environment
where we are told that that's all heresy
right because if you take that approach
you can't get looked at and immediately
been put and be put in a box
and be be labeled and be dismissed
or embraced on the basis of what it is
that you concluded
it is it it is actually responsive
to what the research says and i want
like you and i have talked
extensively on here in the past about
why we don't like to say you know
what the data say right like it's not
it's not about data driven it's about
having a model of the universe
and testing that model over and over and
over and over again
and whichever parts of that model
keep on persisting keep on not being
falsified as you test your assumptions
and your ideas and your predictions over
and over and over again
they the longer they persist the greater
the chance is that what you've got there
is a bit of the truth a bit of reality
that is actually reflective of this
objective universe that we live in
regardless of what anyone else says
about it yeah yes
the uh let's put it this way the level
of our failure does not appear to be
closely connected to the difficulty of
the problem it's a difficult problem but
it's amazing what people have put
together and then
somehow we are going to ignore or
demonize or whatever out of existence
who knows what cost that's right
oh could we want to say something about
our erstwhile mayor or
uh or should we save that maybe very
quickly it's quite timely
yeah it is yeah um so i have it here
if um yeah you wanna
okay
yeah why don't you show it so this is
what a two-minute
so it's it's playing oh no it's playing
on my computer not on
i do not know what just happened okay
you can show my computer if you want
because i've also got it
oh okay i can't play it well okay
we can sort of uh say what it is that
ted here has
yeah so uh
this is actually a quote um my ted
wheeler is speaking
um i think this is yesterday
um in the wake of riots by antifa
throughout i think it was north or
northeast portland
um on new year's eve and including
attacks on the federal buildings
downtown in downtown which is the
northwest or southwest whatever right
across the river um
and you know it's just it's just so much
of the same
garbage that's been happening since the
end of may almost almost uninterrupted
um and should we just go on or should we
let him show it
um yeah why don't you show it okay
my good faith efforts at de-escalation
have been met with ongoing violence
and even scorn from radical antifa
and anarchists in response
it will be necessary to use additional
tools
and to push the limits of the tools we
already have
to bring the criminal destruction and
violence to an end
lawlessness and anarchy
come at great expense and with great
risk
to the future of our community it's time
to push back harder
against those who are set on destroying
our community
and to take more risks in fighting
lawlessness
in closing once again i condemn
anyone who engages in violence or
criminal destruction
no matter what their ideology
all right so that is our mayor
finally figuring out which way is up
it's about time it's amazingly overdue
which you know one does not want to
punish the man for finally
realizing that he's going to have to
enforce the goddamn law against
people who are willfully destroying
things in pursuit of
at best a nonsensical utopian vision
of portland and how the rest of the
world should look
yeah now i did notice and i thought it
was particularly delightful
that in his statement he says
my good faith efforts a de-escalation
had been met with
ongoing violence and even
scorn right as if violence weren't bad
enough
there has been scorn my but i think he's
actually
surprised and actually a little hurt
that they don't love him for all of his
efforts he is they never will
no it's they they they won't
they will they will never come to adopt
you ted no
they won't and hopefully that message
sticks because if i am not mistaken he
is in the process of regrowing a pair
i mean he is let us hope yes he has
landed
on his seasonally appropriate grounds
breeding spot and he's
regrown a pair he is regrowing a pair it
will no longer be true if this
process continues that the only thing
about him that is male is his pronouns
all right i don't know why i said it but
he does have three pronouns i've never
seen three pronouns before he declares
three pronouns not just the usual two
you gotta be well covered he him his
yep he does so anyway this is uh good
news that he will be
enforcing the law um he does i mean if
you think you will well let's put it
this way
i think that this state might actually
be fed up i think at this point he has
realized that there's no
there's nothing down this road right and
it is amazing to though i mean these
people
literally lit his building on fire
with his neighbors present right and he
apologized to the neighbors
and moved he moved i mean i think
apologizing to the neighbors made good
sense but um
actually i'm not even sure he apologized
i think he might have apologized to
antifa
he did okay zach says he apologized to
the neighbors but in any case um as
residents of portland
it is about time it is amazing that it
took so long to get here let us hope
that he does a good and competent job he
does say the right things in that clip
about the fact that um we will need to
avail ourselves of new technologies and
apply the ones we've got
hopefully it's done well but um that
sounds ominous
okay it does but nonetheless you know
you have ongoing
lawlessness obviously there's no choice
here so
um well i mean they could have fully
availed themselves for the technologies
they had from the beginning
well in fact i think that would have
worked he kept taking them off the table
exactly yeah
yeah so it's uh yeah uh it is good news
hopefully it works out
all right all right maybe we have
reached the end i think we have reached
the
first live stream of episode 61.
yes so we will take a 15-minute break
and for those of you who are watching on
youtube be back
for our second hour hour plus to answer
your questions super chat questions that
you ask in this hour and in the next
hour
we have um that new first against the
wall club
stuff available at
www.store.darkhorsepodcast.com
darkhorse.moderatorgmail.com can be
emailed with logistical questions like
how do i pose a question when is the
private q a
speaking of the private q a that's
available on my patreon once a month
we did ours uh last week
man of the question's good they're so
good and it's a lot of fun
and it's small enough that we can watch
the chat as it happens and actually
interact
with the chat some which you know we
never see the chat but no scorn
please keep the scorn to violence is
okay
uh no i would say uh it's limited by
virtue of the technology but you know
you could sneak a lot of scorn through a
chat
but i appreciate it if they didn't yeah
yeah please please give the scorn to a
dull roar
um you have your second monthly patreon
conversation tomorrow
evolution conversation will happen
tomorrow had the coalition of the
reasonable conversation this morning it
was uh
quite excellent as it has as it has been
and um in the next hour we will among
the other questions that you guys asked
during super chat
also as has become our want answer a
question voted on on the discord server
which you can also access at either our
patreons and
maybe that's it happy new year to
everyone get outside
that's it yes happy new year i hope to
be joining you in 2021
shortly all right be well
hurry up